do you think there's a distinction
between
the concept of learning and the concept
of reasoning
do you think it's possible for neural
networks
to reason so i think of it slightly
differently so
for me uh learning is whenever i can
like make a snap judgment so if you show
me a picture of a dog i can immediately
say it's a dog
but if you give me like a puzzle you
know like uh whatever a
goldsberg machine of like things going
to happen then i have to reason because
i've never
it's a very complicated setup i've never
seen that particular setup and i really
need to
you know draw and like imagine in my
head what's going to happen to figure it
out
uh so i think yes neural networks are
really good at
recognition but they're not very good at
reasoning because they're like if
they have seen something before you or
seen something similar before they're
very good at making those sort of snap
judgments
but if you were to give them a very
complicated thing that they've not seen
before
they have very limited ability right now
to compose different things like oh i've
seen this particular part before i've
seen this particular part before
and now probably like this is how
they're going to work in tandem it's
very hard for them to come up with these
kinds of things
well there's a certain aspect to uh
reasoning that you can maybe convert
into the process of programming
and so there's the whole field of
program synthesis and
people have been applying machine
learning to the problem of programming
synthesis and the question is you know
can they
the step of composition why can't that
be learned
you know this this step of like building
things on top of like little intuitions
concepts on top of each other
can that be learnable what's your
intuition there
or like i guess similar set of
techniques do you think they'll be
applicable so i think it is of course
it is learnable because like we are
prime examples of machines that have
like or
individuals that have learned this right
like humans have learned this so it is
of course
it is a technique that is very easy to
learn uh
i think where we are kind of hitting a
wall basically with like current machine
learning
is the fact that when the network learns
all of this information
we basically are not able to figure out
how well it's going to generalize to an
unseen thing
yeah and we have no like a priori no way
of characterizing that
and i think that's basically telling us
a lot about
like a lot about the fact that we really
don't know what this model has learned
and how well it's basically
because we don't know how well it's
going to transfer there's also a sense
in which it feels like
we humans may not be aware of how much
like background how good our background
model is
how much knowledge we just have slowly
building on top of each other
it feels like neural networks are
constantly throwing stuff out like
you'll do some incredible thing where
you're learning
a particular task in computer vision you
celebrate your state of the art
successes and you throw that out
like it feels like it's you're never
using
stuff you've learned for your future
successes in in other domains
and humans are obviously doing that
exceptionally well uh still throwing
stuff away
in their mind but keeping certain
kernels of truth
right so i think we're like continual
learning is sort of the paradigm for
this in machine learning and i don't
think it's a very well explored paradigm
yeah uh we have like things in deep
learning for example right catastrophic
forgetting is like one of the
standard things the thing basically
being that if you teach a network like
to recognize dogs
and now you teach that same networker to
recognize cats it basically forgets how
to recognize dogs so it forgets very
quickly
i mean and whereas a human if you were
to teach someone to recognize dogs and
then to
recognize cats they don't forget
immediately how to recognize these dogs
i think that's basically sort of what
you're trying to get yeah i just i
wonder if like the long-term memory
mechanisms
or the mechanisms that store not just
memories but
concepts that allow you to uh
to the reason uh like and and and
compose
concepts if those things will look very
different than neural networks or if you
can do that within a
single neural network with some
particular sort of architecture quirks
uh that seems to be a really open
problem and of course i go up and down
on that because it's um
there's something so compelling to the
uh to the symbolic ai or to um
the ideas of logic based sort of expert
systems you have like
human interpretable facts that built on
top of each other
it's really annoying like with
self-supervised learning
that uh the ai is not very explainable
like you can't like understand all the
beautiful things as
has learned you can't ask it like
questions
um but then again maybe that's a stupid
thing for us humans to want
right i think whenever we try to like
understand it we're putting our own
subjective human bias into it
yeah and i think that's the sort of
problem with self-supervisor i think the
goal is that
it should learn naturally from the data
so now if you try to understand it you
are
using your you're using your own
preconceived notions of what this model
has learned
and that's the problem
you